Hello, everybody.
My name is Greg Swinehart.
I have worked at
RStudio for a long time.
This is going to be a different
kind of talk for rstudio::conf,
because I'm not
a data scientist.
I'm a graphic designer.
Like I graduated in
the social sciences.
So why on earth am I
up here to talk to you?
I'm asking myself the
exact same question.
Let's see,
can we get my slides
up here on the screen?
Here we go.
So I started, I think, the
first design I did for RStudio,
I think three people
work there at the time.
And I joined full time
about 4 and 1/2 years ago.
I made this back in
the day actually,
and this started out as
a shirt a couple of years
before hexes were even a thing.
Joe reached out
and said, I kind of
want to make a baseball
shirt with this thing
I've been working on.
Can you make us
a shirt that says
Shiny and kind of baseball font?
And then when hexes came
around, we controversially
went with the baseball font
where all the other hexes
had a different font.
It was very it was there were
some tense conversations,
but we got it.
Now it's no big deal, of course.
So a few months ago, I
moved over to the Shiny team
to see what you all
have been working on
and see if maybe we could update
some things in the process.
What we're going
to talk about today
is kind of what I've seen
in the last couple of months
and what we've begun
to work on to build
some new functionality
for you, to make
your lives a little bit easier.
So I'm going to talk about three
simple design principles that
might help your Shiny apps look
and feel a little bit better,
as you're building them. And
also show some of the new work
that we've just begun
to help your apps look
and feel a little bit
better automatically.
All right.
So what's it like to
be a graphic designer?
I hate it.
I seriously hate it.
I HATE IT.
You guys know what
I'm talking about.
Like you're looking at a thing
and it's just not working.
It is horrible sometimes.
I mean, don't get me
wrong, 99% of the time,
it's like the greatest
thing I could possibly
be doing with my time.
It's the joy of
my life to do it.
But then when you
get to that thing,
you guys know what
I'm talking about.
Like you have that thing, it
just doesn't look or feel right
and you start to meddle with
some things to try and fix it.
And there's a million different
directions you could go
and none of them are working.
And then it's just
like AAAAAHHHH, I hate it.
So I just bring
that up to say that,
I understand what you're
going through sometimes when
you're making your apps and
you're trying to make them
look good, we totally get it.
And, we're working on it.
We're trying to make this world
a little bit easier for you.
Here's here's how
I think of design.
Design as a form of
communication, communicating
well, is really
difficult. Constructing
the perfect message
is a lot of work.
And then if you add the
complexity of saying it
in a way that your audience will
hear, or even pay attention to,
it can really feel
like nearly impossible.
So putting an app
in front of somebody
in my mind, all the work
that you guys are doing,
it's like having a
conversation with them.
And that's why I'm here to talk
about how designing for people
is hard.
Maybe, you tell me,
maybe 10% of the work
that you're doing when you're
working on a Shiny app,
is frontend work.
And yet you're supposed to have
this rock solid data and also
an amazing UI and UX
experience for your users.
That's a really big ask.
So our goal here
is for you to be
able to make better and
more beautiful apps.
And maybe have that even
take up less of your time.
That's kind of what we're
trying to work towards.
So when I got to the Shiny team,
they asked me one
question, how can we
make Shiny apps look better?
Side question, please tell us it
doesn't involve HTML and CSS.
Historically, the
benefit of Shiny
has been can make something
decent without knowing
HTML and CSS.
But admittedly, as
Joe said yesterday,
there have been gaps in
improving this default look.
Joe recognized a
long list of people
in the community who
have stood in this gap,
like David Granjon
and his work on bs4dash.
Without the work of David
and how many other people
were on that list, it
was like 1,000,006,
the apps would still look
like they were 10 years old,
probably.
Right now without
adding on some things,
a fresh, Shiny app can
look a little stale.
So where do we start?
Well, there's two things I
want to talk about today.
Look and functionality.
Look as kind of its default
theme and functionality
is the components that we're
serving up to you so that you
can kind of present your data.
Let's start with look.
Which means....
You need to have some real talk.
Shiny uses Bootstrap 3
to render its UI
and Bootstrap 3
was created in 1852
(I don't know the exact date.)
So Shiny looks stale because
Bootstrap 3, this year,
looks kind of stale.
And this is not to speak
ill of Bootstrap 3.
When it came out,
it was a miracle.
But if you're going to
make a new Shiny app,
the best first step
you can take right now
is to start with the
latest Bootstrap.
And right now that
is Bootstrap 5.
Bootstrap 5 will make it look
much more contemporary right
out of the box.
It has more components
for us to serve to you.
You has better accessibility
tools, which is amazing.
And, of course, it
makes your app look
responsive and appropriate for
whatever size screen it's on.
So how do you do this?
You can easily do this.
It's almost like... I was
looking at how they do this.
It's literally
like somebody said,
"hey, Siri, make
this Bootstrap 5."
That's kind of like what
they do, and they do it
with this R package
called bslib,
by someone who could only be
described as the greatest
human being on the planet.
Carson Sievert, he
is really done...
[STANDING OVATION, PEOPLE CRYING]
Yeah...
This guy has done the Lord's work
for like 2.5 years to make
this process easy for you.
You might remember that Joe
Cheng mentioned bslib
at the 2020 conference.
He actually gave a
whole talk about it.
So bslib provides tools
to easily customize Bootstrap
and therefore your app's
appearance directly
from R, allowing
you to quickly change
the appearance of
your Shiny apps
and for that matter,
R Markdown and Quarto stuff.
Today we're going to
talk just about Shiny.
But it can't be
overstated how easy
it is to change your
Shiny app's appearance,
to match your
organization's branding
with just a few lines of code.
This is where I come from.
We need this thing, but it
has to have our branding.
(There's some happy
bslib in there...)
This is where I come from.
We need this, and we need it
to look like Johnson &amp; Johnson.
And it's kind of
like, all right, well,
I'm going to look at the red.
We've got to make it red.
We got to look at the typeface.
There's a couple of
key Sass variables
that you can target
to really kind change
the look of your entire thing.
bslib can make it
very simple with one or two
lines of code or it gives
you access to all, what is it,
1,400 different Sass variables
to change your Bootstrap theme.
And so you can go
as deep as you want.
And this should be in kind of
a scalable, reproducible way.
Right?
So bslib is unbelievable, OK.
So that's look, you're
off to a great start.
If you update your bootstrap
to Bootstrap 5 with bslib,
maybe you're putting
in a couple of colors
to match your
organization's branding.
Let's move on to
functionality, and get
to some design principles
that occurred to me while I
was looking through
any Shiny app
I could get my hands on in
the last couple of months.
I've been poring
through all of them
from the simplest ones to
some of them are behemoths...
They're crazy, they're nuts.
But everything in
there is important.
You can't judge it.
And a few different design principles
came to mind while
I looked at them.
And when I was discussing
with those with the team,
we started coming up with
new functionality in reaction
to those design principles.
So let's get started.
The first one comes from the
Gestalt Principles of Design.
Now, whether designers
know it or not,
they're building things with
these principles in mind
or as the foundation.
If you're following
them, people will
be able to easily
look at your app.
If you're breaking
them, you kind of
don't want to look
at the app anymore.
Every designer is using this,
whether they know it or not.
So the first one
well, actually, I
wanted to say that
Gestalt psychology is
about 100 years old,
and it is all about how
we process visual information.
When you look at something,
it turns out you kind of look
at the whole of something.
You don't look at
the parts of it.
Like when you look
at a bike, you
don't go, well, look at that
little pedal right there.
Well, there's two pedals here.
Oh, my gosh.
There's wheels right next to it.
What's going on here?
And like hand like,
you don't do that.
You look at it and
you go, that's a bike.
And if you want to specific
things about the bike,
you can then zero in.
Same thing with web design.
You want that kind
of whole thing
to immediately be something
that they want to dive into.
So the first principle that
I want to talk about here
is proximity: Users will
mentally group together
objects that are spatially
close to each other.
Now they're going to
do this no matter what.
So if you have information
on one side of your screen
that's discussing
something, that's
on the other side
of your screen,
they're probably going
to group that information
with something else over here.
And then realize, well,
that's not quite right,
and they're going to start
fishing around for what
they should group that with.
It's really better if you
just keep things in proximity.
You know, like one of
the most popular UX
books over the last 22 years
is called Don't Make Me Think.
We're really trying to
serve this up in a way
so that they don't have
to, like, process too much.
They can just engage
with what you're trying
to show them in your app.
So what I want to do is
kind of show you some things
that I saw.
I saw this quite a
bit and just kind
of give you an example
of what proximity means.
Right here.
We've got a paragraph on the
left side and the sidebar.
And it's speaking
about something
in this kind of right
part of the screen.
In a perfect world, those
would be closer in proximity
and that thing wouldn't
be in the sidebar
that language would
be over near the thing
that it's referencing.
Also saw this.
And this isn't
horrible, but this
is a title that kind of says
this, that and the other thing.
And it's talking
about the three things
underneath that are about
this, that and the other thing.
It's not horrible.
It's kind of nice
serving up what's
coming below on a platter,
but it would be really nice
if this and that
and the other thing
were more closely in
proximity with the thing they
were actually referencing.
And I'm also seeing
this quite a bit.
There are controls that are
kind of somewhere on your screen
that control somewhere
else on your screen, inputs
and outputs, right?
And so I've
seen them where
you have to start
messing with them
to see what they control.
It'd be better if those
controls were closer to what
they actually controlled.
So let's clean
this up real quick.
We'll move this
paragraph over here.
This, that and the other thing.
And this really just
says, like, we update
this on Wednesday mornings.
Let's clean that
up a little bit.
Let's put the controls
actually where they need
to be to control something.
It's starting to look
a little bit cleaner, right?
We're causing the user
to think less before they
engage with this thing.
But, do you notice how none
of these cards on the screen
are the same height?
Or in some cases, not
even the same width.
Don't you wish they
were kind of sized
like this, where the gap in
between, the gutter in between
was the same?
There's actually a design
principle behind this.
Maybe you didn't notice it,
but now that I pointed it out,
did it kind of make
your skin crawl?
This is called order:
Things that are aligned
and symmetrical are more
easily processed.
When a person opens up your app.
You know what?
Let's make them not
think as much as we can
and let them really dive into
the meat and potatoes
of what you're trying to do.
What you're trying to tell them.
All right, so let's
clean this up.
Got a bunch of things here.
All right.
This is starting to look
a little bit better.
With proximity and
order, your users
spend less time
trying to figure out
how your thing works
and more time using it the
way you intend them to.
But really, I've just kind
of been moving stuff around,
right?
These are nice things to
keep in mind while you're
building your app, but your
mind is really in other places
while you're writing your
R code and putting
together your data, right?
So we were trying to
figure out, is there
something here that we
can put in the process
so that it can kind of
put up some guardrails?
So while you're
building these apps,
you'll kind of stay
in the lane and you
don't have to think about
proximity because you're
kind of just building everything
in proximity automatically.
We realize this was the
first piece of functionality
we should address.
That's a card.
A lot of cards oftentimes
become a dashboard.
And from what I can tell,
everybody in this room
is like the Oprah of dashboards.
You're just like,
you get a dashboard,
you'll get a dashboard,
look on your seat.
We all have a dashboard.
So a lot of
dashboards everywhere.
And I get it.
You know how to make them.
Your users know how
to consume them.
Everybody wins.
Bootstrap 3
didn't have cards.
Guess what?
Bootstrap 5 does, so...
We decided cards should become
a first class citizen of Shiny
within bslib and that they
should look good automatically,
so...
We decided this,
and then we didn't
hear from Joe Cheng
for a day or two.
And he came back with, of
course a fully-fledged card API
for us to put in bslib.
And this is what they look by
default. Pretty simple stuff.
You get a card header
for a title, this, that,
or the other thing.
You have a main area
for whatever you want.
It can be an image, it can
be a plot, can be some prose,
a button, whatever
you can think of,
you can throw it in there.
And if there's any
tertiary information,
like we updated
this the other day...
Throw that at the bottom.
This does a lot of the design,
the proximity  the rder
heavy lifting for you.
Check this out.
Here's a row of
cards by example.
Here's what it would look like.
No matter what you put in them,
they will be the same height.
Because you know what?
We're all grown ups in
this room and maybe we
can have nice things.
Something Bootstrap doesn't
offer but we think
is really important
is sometimes you
want to be able to tweak the
parameters of what is inside
the card or maybe even
just kind of change
wholesale, what's
showing in this card.
And so you guys are very
used to using tabs and menus
and dropdowns.
And so when you put that same
code within this card context,
it will look like
this and give you
the functionality of changing
what's inside the card.
If you want to make
dashboards right now,
you're probably using flexdashboard,
and why wouldn't you?
So simple, so
clean... For a lot of you,
that's all you need.
If you want a little bit
more functionality,
you're probably
using Shiny Dashboard
or maybe you're using bs4dash.
We're building out in
bslib, on top of Bootstrap 5,
A new UI toolkit for bslib.
And once we're done, you'll be
able to use its elements
à la carte.
You'll be able to kind
of grab what you need
and not grab the rest.
Basically, you won't have to
import admin LTE to just put
a box around something.
The things you love about
those other packages
will be available in
bslib and therefore, you'll
be able to use them in
Shiny, R Markdown, Quarto.
This is more of, Joe called
it a library approach,
more of a library approach.
Grab what you need
just right there
and hopefully the
design will look good.
If you need to change some
of the branding, go for it.
That's pretty easy, too.
Not everything needs
to be a dashboard,
but bringing in a little
dashboard elements
now and then to your app can
be a pretty powerful thing.
Pretty good thing
for your users.
So let's talk about your users.
last thing I want to
talk about is just
information architecture,
not from Gestalt,
but it's when you
look at your app,
let's say you've narrowed down
all of the content to as little
as it can be, and it's
still kind of a mess.
It's still kind of
hard to engage with.
This is where you can
start kind of prioritizing
what you show based on
the users that you're
going to be presenting
it to, any app you make,
any website you make,
any poster you make,
you could probably prioritize
who is going to engage with it.
You can come up
with three or four
different, three or
five different users.
A lot of people
call them personas.
So let's prioritize based on
who's going to be using it
and just show them
what they need to know.
The way that's
easiest to prioritize
for your different users is
by how much time of theirs you
have.
Some people are going to be
looking at your dashboards,
maybe like a boss is
looking at a dashboard.
They have 30 seconds to
get the main headlines
and then they're
moving on to check out
like 15 other dashboards
of 15 other departments.
Maybe there's a
department leader
that has a couple of minutes,
a couple of times a week.
They probably need
to know everything
that the boss needs to know.
They probably also want
to a little bit more.
So that stuff that
they need to know
if it's too messy
initially to kind of put
that away behind the click.
There's probably a
third person who's
a specialist might spend all
week, every week in your app
and need to respond in real
time to what's happening there.
They might need to
really kind of drill
down and see some very specific
things that are happening.
And so that is OK for them
to click behind the thing.
So what I want to do
is I want to show you
what bslib looks
like in a live example
here, the stuff that
we've been making.
So we've got this sidebar here.
And we have decided that we
had too much in our sidebar.
So we've categorized them into
five different accordion menus.
We're bringing in accordions.
You can have them open
or closed because we
think the boss would want to
engage with these first two.
We open up those and
we close the rest.
Accordions are going to be a
thing that you can kind of put
in wherever you want.
Doesn't have to
be in the sidebar.
All right.
So now we're going to engage
with this a little bit.
Let's see.
We're going to bring in button
groups from Bootstrap 5
that can also act as
checkboxes or radios.
So in this app, there's
three different airports.
Let's see, where do
we want to fly to?
I obviously want
to fly to Hawaii.
And I don't know
where Bob Hope is.
Is that Palm Springs?
I like Bob Hope.
So we'll do that.
All right.
So just for fun, let's
close these because.
That's fun.
Here's another thing
we can do where
we're working on some
histograms that show with range
sliders, so we bring some more
meaning to a ranch slider,
let people kind of investigate
the data little bit that way.
And this is all kind
of changing
what's showing on the right.
Now, let's move on to the cards here.
Cards are amazing.
Sometimes people put a
lot of cards on a page.
It can get to be a lot.
My rule of thumb is if
you reach seven cards, maybe
it's time to start looking
at making a new page.
But in this case, we've
got this globe here
and it's kind of
showing some data
and it's a little hard to
make out what it's doing,
so we've added a
full screen feature
to make a card go full screen.
And so now you can play
with a bit more real estate.
You can zoom in if you want.
Let's see.
Oh well.
That card to the right.
I zoomed in and I was able to
see a bit more information.
About to get the light here.
So I want to talk
about I want to talk
about value boxes real quick.
We're going to make value boxes.
You can put an icon
up in the corner.
It's just kind of an HTML space.
I was sitting next to the
dude who made plot, so I said,
can we have a
sparkline for an icon?
He said, sure.
This is great for the boss
who is looking at this,
but maybe you want to be able
to click in and see a bit more.
So value boxes can
be full screen.
And you can see
more information.
I don't know if you noticed,
but now there's an x and y-axis,
you can show more stuff.
All right.
I'm about to get the gong here.
So let me just say, I think
this will be especially powerful
when it comes to tables.
All of this comes from
conversations with you.
We'd love to hear
from you and find out
what you're struggling with
and how we can maybe help.
So reach out.
My email is greg at rstudio.com,
and I'd love to hang out.